I submitted a question last week regarding the metastatic prostate cancer with my PSA being 0.1 and
energy deprivation drugs being used. I do still have my prostate and did check out your blog post
on this. You already have me on TV. Go see TV. Go as a great TX track. That's a real clean TX track.
What does that do? It helps decrease the intramuric in six levels, which is really important for
everybody, but it's even more important if you're on loop run for prostate cancer,
prostate clear for other things for the prostate clinic cancer, mushrooms, corsets and tumeric
tumeric and corsets, and both help that intramuric in six, as well clear amino pack. What else do I need
from that blog post? You need andrographis. The clear of this amino mod A is a great source of
andrographis. Four of these a day will give you 250 milligrams of andrographis and I highly suggest
just like as many as much as you can do with your other supplements is to break it into doses.
So if you can break it into four, you don't take one in the morning, when you wake up,
in a new time, what a four o'clock and one before you go to bed that even be the best. So a lot of
studies and hydrographis with the prolonged the benefits of energy deprivation therapy.
I highly recommend that. This also has just some other anti-inflammatories and it's a really good thing to
calm the inflammation and this is like a perfect supplement for anybody doing that.